on this thursday night
vaccine drills before canadians get the
shot
ottawa's plan to rehearse the rollout
everyone be ready everyone will be
comfortable the people will be trained
and canada could approve the first
vaccines by mid-december
a blunt message from manitoba's premier
to pandemic deniers
if you don't think that kovid's real
you're an idiot plus quebec's u-turn
on christmas gatherings global news
investigates the spread of covet 19
lies the three countries targeting
canadians with falsehoods
and tunnel vision i think we'd all be
horrified if if things went ahead
causing damage to those sites a
controversial proposal
merging with a prehistoric monument
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with new information about
covid19 vaccines and canada's plan to
roll out the largest mass vaccination
program in canadian history
health canada could approve the first
vaccine in 7 to 10 days
it's likely to be the pfizer biotech
vaccine
the first dose is enough to inoculate
three million canadians
could arrive from pfizer in early
january or sooner
that vaccine must be kept ultra cold so
pfizer will deliver it directly to 14
locations across canada
where special freezers will be in place
to store it the government says it hopes
to have those sites up and running by
december 14th
canada's deputy chief public health
officer says naming an exact date of
when the first doses will be delivered
is less important than being ready we
shouldn't
be so obsessed about the quote actual
delivery of the vaccines themselves you
know the dates and so on i think
what what's really important is the fact
that we're we're planning preparing and
doing exercise
so that uh once the vaccine actually
technically arrived and will everyone
be ready approving the vaccines is the
role of health canada as
is deciding how many doses each region
gets it's expected they will be
distributed on a per capita basis
it will be up to the provinces and the
territories to actually administer the
vaccines
abigail beeman explains what we know
about the plans and
what is still uncertain i kind of like
the idea of
being ready before the christmas time
frame so that we're certain to be ready
when it comes in january while none of
the four vaccines under review has been
approved officials believe
pfizer will be first that manufacturer
will deliver the product directly to
locations across the country
there are 14 being set up and the major
general leading logistics says the goal
is to have
all 14 ready to go by december 14th
there's a dry run happening monday they
execute the process
of handling and ensuring that people are
comfortable
with this very unique the very unique
requirements of handling a
ultra low temperature vaccine as for
vaccine approvals
we expect a decision soon and certainly
we expect it to be a favorable one
but in the meantime we're not just
sitting still and sitting on our heads
health canada says it's still waiting on
some key information from manufacturers
which could come as soon as friday
part of that information is really
around the manufacturing process
and which specific lots may be destined
for canada and it's really
important that we get that information
and we have good information about the
quality assurance checks
on those the military will be involved
in the rollout and a planning directive
obtained by global news says in order
for the supply chain to be set
and ready for delivery before the new
year they need vaccine approvals
the number of doses per province and
guidance about who gets the vaccine
first the chief of the defense staff
calling for that by
no later than early december the
government hasn't announced any of that
and it's december 3rd in the absence of
clear answers and certain things we
always make assumptions and work on
those assumptions
and work to turn assumptions into facts
the government is planning for 205
vaccine delivery points across the
country
with provinces and territories deciding
the specifics
abigail beeman global news ottawa
canada is following the same timeline
and getting the same data for vaccine
approval as the u.s
and today america's top infectious
disease doctor anthony fauci said the uk
which approved the pfizer vaccine
yesterday rushed the approval process
and that he said could fuel vaccine
skepticism
you know i love the brits they're great
they're good scientists but they just
took the data from the fisa company and
instead of scrutinizing it
really really carefully they said okay
let's approve it that's
it the fda the united states of america
food and drug administration
is the gold standard of regulation
they're doing it in a very careful way
appropriately because if we did anything
that was cutting corners and rushing
we have enough problem with people being
skeptical
about taking a vaccine anyway fauci
later said he didn't mean to imply the
uku's sloppy practices
just that getting the vaccines is not a
race and being first is not as important
as being safe and prepared there are no
vaccines approved yet of course and even
if and when they are it will take
months for everyone in canada to get it
right now there is still a crisis
unfolding
especially in alberta today that
province broke another daily record more
than
eighteen hundred new cases reported and
fourteen more albertans have died
the test positivity rate there is now
nine point five percent
and because premier kenny has put in
only modest restrictions it's expected
the virus will keep spreading virtually
unchecked
now contingency plans are being made to
build field hospitals to hold the sick
and dying
heather urex west reports they have come
to be a symbol of the kovit 19 pandemic
field hospitals erected in a hurry after
existing hospitals are
overwhelmed alberta may not be there yet
but the province has asked both the red
cross and the federal government for
help
should that time come this is you know
conversations about a contingency plan
which
health officials should be doing both
those in the mystery and
those in ahs alberta's former chief
medical officer of health says while
it's prudent to prepare for what's to
come
preventing these worst case scenarios
should be the priority
and so far he says alberta has not done
what it needs to in order to bend the
curve
the window is closing that's what
happens with exponential growth you know
you cannot
alberta health services personnel and
the planning they've done have been
first great i mean the performance has
been first rate
but no system can deal with 2 4 8
16 32 times as many cases as they had
before we've seen that positivity rate
bounce around between seven and nine
percent over the past week or ten days
in fact alberta's test positivity rate
has been steadily rising
from one percent in early october five
percent by november first
to more than nine percent now but
instead of discussing new restrictions
wednesday
the premier focused on next year's
vaccine later sharing a graphic on
social media that declared in big
letters
alberta will not make any vaccine
mandatory even though
nobody in canada has suggested otherwise
i think that what we're seeing is a
pattern
where there's a real desire not to
offend the people who don't want to wear
masks the people who don't want to get
vaccines
there's this sense that personal liberty
is
an equal value to public health that
path
has led to disaster elsewhere places
like the us that have had to use field
hospitals too
which leaves alberta in a perilous
position as it inches closer
to a point of no return heather eurix
west global news
calgary alberta isn't the only province
struggling in
quebec today 470 new cases were reported
and 30 more people died
and today quebec's premier backtracked
on his plan to allow people to gather
over christmas
francois lago admits he never should
have allowed the plan
he says it's just not safe i know
would all like to see our family
but it's not a good idea the virus is
very dangerous
we need to stay home and get some rest
and we have to take care of one another
manitoba premier brian pallister came
close to tears today as he begged people
to follow public health restrictions
over the holidays i'm the guy who's
stealing christmas
to keep you safe because you need to do
this now
you need to do the right thing because
next year we'll have
lots to celebrate you don't even like me
i hope in years to come you might
respect me for having the guts to tell
you the right thing
and here's the right thing stay safe
protect each other love each other care
for each other you got so many ways to
show that
but don't get together this christmas
some breaking news from toronto tonight
an elementary school there is being
closed until at least wednesday so a
covid19 outbreak can be investigated
three teachers walked off the job at
thorncliffe park public school this
morning because of an outbreak
24 students and two teachers have tested
positive last week the school completed
a pilot project to test for asymptomatic
cases and four percent of those tested
came back positive thorncliff park is
canada's largest
elementary school there is a warning
tonight about foreign entities suspected
of spreading disinformation about covet
19
the canadian security intelligence
service is named a trio of countries
iran
russia and china in a confidential
report obtained by global news
as david aiken reports they appear to
have a clear and sinister
objective stay at home
wear a mask avoid social gatherings
canada's government has tried to be
consistent in its covenant messaging
but foreign governments hostile to
canada have quite a different message
for canadians
it becomes an issue of how do we as
canadians learn to live with
this disinformation environment while
still having confidence
in our democratic institutions the
canadian security intelligence service
or csis
says china russia and iran have all been
linked to pandemic disinformation
campaigns
they've spread falsehoods about the
virus and conspiracy theories
such as suggesting 5g telecom towers
cause coven 19. the objective
increased mistrust and suspicion in
western governments
and in western public health authorities
they're very cheap to do it doesn't cost
a lot to set up a bot army or to put out
doctored photos or to spread
conspiracies on a website relative to
other kind of intelligence activities
global news obtained 170 pages of
confidential threat assessments prepared
by csis last may
for the prime minister and all cabinet
members the records were obtained by an
access to information request and
parts have been heavily blacked out by
government sensors
still the warnings were clear russia was
actively spreading disinformation
blaming the west for the virus
as part of a broader campaign to
discredit the west
china is focused on a propaganda
campaign that protects its own
reputation
and domestic legitimacy while toting its
pandemic aid abroad
as for the regime in iran an increased
disinformation campaign
seeks to shift blame for domestic
shortcomings in
handling kova 19 to foreign actors
i think the most effective campaigns
that are out there are ones that
play on previously existing grievances
now experts are divided as to how
effective these disinformation campaigns
are but the concern now
is that foreign actors may try to
disrupt vaccination programs
about to get underway here in canada and
elsewhere in the west
donna okay david aiken in ottawa thanks
the federal government has moved to
fulfill a promise to enshrine the u.n
declaration on the rights of indigenous
peoples
in canadian law the legislation is a
significant step forward on the shared
path to reconciliation
for indigenous and non-indigenous
peoples alike
it has the potential to be
transformational
if path bill c-15 would require the
federal government to work with first
nations inuit and metis to ensure
canadian law
is in harmony with the rights and
principles contained in the un
declaration
the government would be required to
create an action plan for those goals
no later than three years after the bill
receives royal assent
the national chief of the assembly of
first nations says that
is not fast enough we've waited too long
already
we don't want to wait for another three
years and before the bill is adopted
into law
we also want clarity on which government
department will take the lead on this
crucial initiative
canada was one of only four countries to
vote against the original un declaration
back in 2007
and british columbia became the first
province to enshrine the declaration
just over
a year ago after a break we take you to
the u.s
coming up the grim predictions ahead for
america's covid19 crisis
there is no light at the end of the
covid19 tunnel in the u.s right now
more than 2 800 americans died yesterday
in one day that is getting close to a 9
11 event
every day hospitals are swamped doctors
and nurses exhausted
and the peak is a long way off jennifer
johnson reports
u.s medical experts predict the worst
days of the coven 19 pandemic are still
to come
the centers for disease control and
prevention predicts another 200
000 americans could die from the virus
in the next two months
i actually believe they're going to be
the most difficult time in the public
health history of this nation with over
one hundred thousand people in hospitals
the american ambulance association says
its emergency system is at a breaking
point
many areas are already out of icu beds
los angeles is on track to run out of
hospital beds by christmas
it is a real possibility that healthcare
workers are going to have to make
choices we're going to have to triage
who gets care and who doesn't
when health systems get stressed that's
what happens
a devastating scenario for too many
hospital workers
it's overwhelming and we're doing the
best we can nursing homes have been hit
the hardest spending more money than
ever trying to keep
residents virus free now the american
health care association says the
pandemic
could put 70 percent of struggling
nursing homes out of business
there has to be a national plan strategy
in order to combat
what is coming down the road federal
officials hope covet 19 vaccines will
start rolling out in mid-december
right after the food and drug
administration issues its eua
emergency use authorization healthcare
workers and nursing home residents
will be the first to receive it we can
get to them in time
and give them the vaccine and help them
live the rest of their lives
relatively healthy millions of people
and businesses are facing bankruptcies
and evictions
congress is debating and inching closer
to passing a 900 billion dollar
coronavirus stimulus bill 12 million
americans are going to lose their
unemployment insurance the day after
christmas merry christmas
anxious americans are desperate for help
as the pandemic continues to
crush families and the u.s economy
jennifer johnson global news washington
a couple was arrested in hawaii after
flying home from san francisco
knowing they had covet 19 wesley morib
and courtney peterson both
tested positive before getting on their
flight they boarded despite being told
to isolate they were arrested on sunday
when they arrived on the island
of kauai
after a mudslide still ahead the search
after a massive rainstorm
in alaska
this is what it looks like in haines
alaska today after a record-breaking
rainstorm multiple mudslides hit the
community yesterday
roads were washed out several houses
buried dozens of residents had to flee
search crews are working their way
through the unstable ground looking for
two people
who are still missing a large explosion
at a wastewater treatment plant in
england has killed four people three
employees and a contractor died and a
fifth person was injured the blast
happened in a holding tank for treated
sewage
witnesses say the explosion was so
powerful it shook the ground
it's unclear what triggered it but
police say it's not terror related and
there's no risk
to the public a big boost for boeing
today the budget airline ryanair wants
to buy 75 more 737 max jets
increasing their order to a total of 210
planes
this american airlines 737 max took to
the skies wednesday in a demonstration
flight
last month the u.s federal aviation
administration gave the green light for
them to fly again
airlines in the u.s will be able to use
the 737 max
after boeing updates critical software
on each plane and pilots receive
training
the 737 jets have been grounded since
march 2019
after crashes in indonesia and ethiopia
killed more than 340 people
including 18 canadians
transport canada is not expecting the
737 max to return to commercial service
before late january or early february at
the earliest
it says different requirements will be
in place in canada for operators
including more flight deck and
pre-flight procedures
next the campaign to stonewall a tunnel
project under stonehenge
i guess this is the thing now right
yep i guess this is a thing now another
metal monolith has appeared this one on
a mountain in california
it's about three meters high and has
three sides it's similar to the one
found in the utah desert
that one was actually there for four
years apparently before anyone stumbled
upon it
it has since been removed but the
mystery over who's erecting these things
remains well stonehenge in the uk is one
of the most recognizable sites in the
world the stone circle has stood on a
plane west of london for about 5 000
years it's a place of pilgrimage for
druids and a place of wonder for
millions of tourists
so a plan to build a road underneath it
has led to outrage
crystal commancing on the backlash to
the stonehenge tunnel
stonehenge with its collection of
prehistoric monuments
is known the world over yet it's what
could soon be
under a portion of the united nations
world heritage site
that some find astounding the way that
he's
suggested that you can put a huge road
through the
through a world heritage site and it
doesn't cause significant damage
or substantial harm seems quite
incredulous to us
britain's transport secretary recently
approved the project despite an
independent planning inspector saying it
would cause
permanent irreversible harm the project
would see a 3.2 kilometer two-lane
tunnel
dug under the iconic site a move said to
improve
traffic flow and commerce the u.n
lobbied against it saying it would
affect stonehenge's outstanding
universal value
construction if it goes ahead could
jeopardize the world heritage site's
designation
the head of highways england argues the
project is an improvement
this tunnel will remove the visibility
of the road from the landscape
it will reduce vehicle noise and it will
restore stonehenge to something like its
original setting
so they say that the tunnel will
potentially
enhance some aspects of the heritage
sites
whilst still acknowledging that there
will be damage to other parts
and we say that sort of offsetting isn't
allowed by
the international conventions the world
heritage convention
stonehenge is one of those iconic world
heritage sites along with maybe the
pyramids and
the taj mahal and i think we'd all be
horrified if if things went ahead
you know causing damage to those sides
the stonehenge alliance formally
asked the government to withdraw
approval for the project
but it hasn't heard back in the meantime
it's rallying support with an online
petition
crystal commencing global news london
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is the winter
version of sandy hook pier in sandy hook
manitoba looks
a bit spooky apparently it gets
dismantled every fall to protect it from
shifting lake ice and then is
reassembled in the spring thanks for
watching robin gill will be here
tomorrow and i'll see you on saturday on
the new reality
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you